no actually Sarah Jane well let's get
some reaction now from the two main
parties with me treasury spokesman priti
patel for the Conservatives and chris
leslie for labor welcome to you indeed
just want to clarify something in this
85 page document a Labour government
will cut the deficit every year what
does that actually mean well rather than
seeing the deficit increase in budgets
throughout the next parliament will make
sure that we reduce it now we're going
to inherit a deficit of what is it 75
billion pounds far more than we were
promised was going to be the case it
should have been gone by now we should
have even been talking about it but we
want to reduce that from 75 billion and
get the current budget into balance and
then surplus as soon as I when you
aren't so when you say cat you mean cut
in cash terms not just percentage of GDP
tones well I hope both I mean I we want
to cut the deficit year after year and
in fact what we've said is that will put
our budget as one of the Budget
Responsibility locks that we've put in
into the page 1 of the manifesto we'll
put that budget to the office for budget
responsibility so they will have to
certify that the measures in the budget
will have that effect and that is a
really important guarantee I mean as we
said as we were hearing there in our
report the Institute of fiscal studies
tesoro be ours representative on earth
aren't too impressed that's where the
big unknown is with Labour's plans how
comfortable how much they will be
comfortable to borrow each year well
except I think what you heard from the
Institute for Fiscal Studies they were
looking at perhaps you know the services
they were worried when do they were they
were looking at the Conservatives fixing
that arbitrary day now we've said yes
the deficit will be gone by 2020 but we
want to try and obviously clear that
sooner if we can and that of course does
depend in part on our ability to get
growth going in the economy so that we
can get a higher wage economy and reduce
the need to subsidize low pay through
all those extra tax credits and get the
revenues flowing in I mean pretty
padella all sounds pretty responsible
they shot your Fox absolutely not Adam I
think what we've heard today from n
Miliband is a fact or the reiteration
again that there is no economic
competence with the Labour Party there
is
no plan B is out it's here it's not
credible Budget Responsibility triple
lock but it's easy to make those
platitudes it's about the substance and
also it's about the track record labour
do not have a solid track record when it
comes to economic competence and also I
think when it comes to some of the
detail you've heard the comments on the
ifs you yourself as refer to them as
well you know the public who want to
want to trust the political parties when
it comes to borrowing taxes and also
differs I'll take it on trust for you
but when they put in black and white you
take it from competence from us as you
seen what we've been doing in the part
last Parliament as well we have been
reducing the deficit while making very
difficult decisions you did promise you
wouldn't have one we have been reducing
the deficit and that's not fair we are
saying onyx said he was going to do it
well we have been reducing the deficit
we reduce the deficit and also we've
been making very difficult public
spending decisions as well and
importantly protecting public services
while making you accept that you have
made now 20 billion pounds of our labor
of claiming of coasted spending promises
no absolutely not we have been clear and
we have said that we will continue lips
are the 8 million wheels we would
continue with the progress that we have
made already during the course of this
Parliament and we will continue to get
the economy back on track making us
difficult public spending choices and
decisions we've been public 30 billion
pounds of consolidation is required and
we will do that from will generate
million we have look I would love to
promise all sorts of things but we've
said and I think it's important that
where we make a promise we say exactly
where the money comes from you can't say
the same in all conscience of what the
Conservatives have been doing racking up
as a panic you know on the health
service on text commitments on what it's
not them who said the health service
needs eight billion yeah well tell us
when the chief executive the king's
phone absolute has told us today about
your manifesto it's a surprise that
labour hasn't matched the pledges of the
other two main parties to put eight
billion pounds more into the NHS by 2020
but also their plans to repeal the
Health and Social Care Act could result
in distract
reorganization and structural change
just when the NHS needs to focus on
delivering better patient care and
saving money so you're the only party
not pledging to come up with the money
with the NHS as it needs you're also
according to them promise take another
top-down reorganization and you say
you're the part of the NHS but do you
really want us to make hollow pledges
and promises that are completely from
fantasy and are not funded we've said
that you know our first step and the
enemy's say the conservatives would
destroy the NHS if they get well I think
I think we know there's a friend of mine
in you're saying you wouldn't find them
but of course look we've said very
clearly our first step in making sure
that we get to some of that the proper
funding is the 2.5 billion of a time to
care fund partly from the mansion tax of
raising on 22 million pound above value
of properties a significant amount of
money for twenty thousand extra notes
and eight thousand doctors now you can
see there we've said where the money
comes from and we say where it goes to
and that's the first step the down
payment towards repairing our any man in
charge of the NHS as he needs more and
we other parties are saying they would
match it and you're saying you wouldn't
but I mean is that is that fair fair
representation that's out his version of
what he thinks that trajectory needs to
be you think you've said no I think I
think it's certainly an important
interpretation of what's needed for the
HIV you haven't got the money but we've
said this is our first step towards it
that 2.5 billion now tell me another
political party that's even put a penny
down for its first step you can with all
the will in the world make all sorts of
promises people want to know where's the
money coming are we going to get a firm
idea of where this 8 billion is going to
come from from the Prime Minister
tomorrow I think what I would say as I'm
is it tomorrow will get a much better
and a positive vision for the future of
our country within the organisation
we're talking about are we going to find
out where the money is that essentially
shoulders when I'm protecting our public
services which is key you know the OHA
you're gonna get v8 we are we are being
clear in terms of where we'll find the
money from will continue we will
continue with the reforms that we've
undertaken so far in consolidation the
public finances but also continue to
invest in the NHS problem with
commitment is very clear we are the only
party that has been doing that with
the problem is on your present model the
man you appointed around the NHS says
you will be running at least eight
billion short if not 22 billion you said
over the weekend you're going to match
that I'm just asking where the money's
going to come we will we will be very
clear in terms of how that commitment
will be made you'll hear more obviously
in terms of the future in the outline of
the manifesto tomorrow but I think we
should be clear that we are the only
party are very clearly putting in the
eight billion that is required and
everything it's a hollow place just a
Hollywood Utah we be committed let's not
get back in the back in December in the
autumn statement we gave 2 billion for
the NHS that money mitted that money we
are compared to front in the NHS that
money is there going into frontline care
for patients but I usually surplus for
example for the next parliament yes we
are committed to that absolutely we are
committed to definitely exactly and the
7 billion tax cut the promise we are
committed to reducing tax and working
families and that essential to our
belief in supporting families and
household but I said I'll take it up
does it but it does that she hasn't
because it is a continuation of what we
have been to you just do what you said
you'd do it Colin you say you get the
job we are the first to say the job is
not yet done in terms of consolidation
the public in consolidation public
finances but importantly having the
ability through responsible management
of the economy to continue to invest in
our public services as well and that is
the difference between on low labour
party is about competence in government
versus the prospect of higher taxes but
working families and work in household
on the web upon you can let us say that
you would spend more on the NHS though I
think it's clear that we are committed
to the NHS and will continue to spread
more than labor I'm thinking a very
clear whole new ticket I was getting is
getting deep and I'm loath to interrupt
this because i think you're actually
defending her down quite well here but
it now occurs to me this is why george
osborne rejected by office for budget
responsibility from auditing the kamir
suspending but we didn't want to do that
I just ask you as things stand with all
your fiscal responsibility in your
triple lock and all that you are
accepting I'm not saying whether it can
be delivered or not
in terms of the basic offer to the
voters of this election that labor is
proposing to spend less on the NHS than
the Conservatives I don't know because I
don't believe that they will spend this
fantasy say the concrete figure that we
know can be delivered is but because
we've taken the tough decision to the
for those living in properties of two
million pounds and above who don't like
our proposal to levy that mansion tax
they don't like that it makes that as
unpopular with them but we've said we
want them to chip in more because our
health service needs it now I think if
you're going to promise extra money
you've got to be able to say where it
came about when you accept their
proximal I don't accept it's a real
promise okay we're gonna have glue thank
you very much